أم تعلم أنك كتبت أيضًا في مقالتك
أن على عكس التصورات أه
تحرك السيد رونالدو هو أكثر من مجرد
تشتيت الانتباه عن
حقوق الإنسان السعودية أه البغيضة أه سجل
الواقع هو أن المملكة العربية السعودية تحاول
جاهدة جدًا أه بقوة شديدة لتغيير
التصورات تجاه  بلد
أم ومن المثير للاهتمام مشاهدة
هذه الرحلة ، ما الذي تفعله من هذه
الجهود
، وكما تقول ، فإن الاستحواذ مثل
كريستيانو رونالدو هو خطوة واحدة نحو
ذلك
جيدًا إذا كنت تأخذ ميزان أه ما ستجلبه
كأس العالم إلى الحضيض
على الرغم من  انتقادات لاذعة على أه
قضية حقوق العمال في قضية
مزاريب حقوق المثليين تخرج من هذا أه
الساطع لذا فإن السعوديين سينظرون إلى هذا
ويقولون بشكل أساسي يمكننا فعل الشيء نفسه
فهو مهم بالنسبة لهم لسببين
أحدهما هو الصورة السعودية
مشكلة السمعة تذهب إلى ما هو أبعد من
حقوق الإنسان ، فهي تعود إلى مملكة
كانت على مدار 70 عامًا
شديدة السرية ومحافظة على
النزعة العنصرية.  تفسير الإسلام
عالميًا ويذهب إلى حقيقة أن
المملكة العربية السعودية أه وولي العهد الأمير
محمد أه سلمان
تريد على وجه التحديد إعادة هيكلة الاقتصاد السعودي
وجعله من أهم
الاقتصادات في مجموعة العشرين
مجموعة أكبر الاقتصادات في العالم.
العالم ويريد التنويع بعيدًا
عن الاعتماد على عائدات النفط ولذلك
تلعب السمعة دورًا كبيرًا جدًا في
ذلك وطبعًا الاستحواذ على رونالدو
أه يدعم هذا الجهد